welcome back to cbs this morning two
months ago back-to-back storms left the
city of jackson mississippi
without water for weeks it's just one
example of
massive problems with the infrastructure
meant to keep americans safe
wesley lowery recently visited jackson
for 60 minutes plus
here's what he discovered
thousands of jackson residents like
gaynor were left for weeks without the
most
vital public utility and the most basic
human necessity
cars lined up for miles at water and
food distribution sites set up across
the city
when the american society of civil
engineers released its most recent
report card
mississippi received a d for the quality
of both its drinking water
and wastewater infrastructure but when
we traveled to jackson last month
we found much more than a water crisis
but the story of a city
and a nation still grappling with the
shaky foundation upon which it was
constructed
how often is there a crew out here
digging into someone's yard like this
uh this is pretty pretty regularly
pretty regular unfortunately
when you look at uh
charles williams is jackson's public
works director and it's his job to
manage the city's infrastructure
it's thankless work even under normal
circumstances
much less amid a wave of winter weather
a typical
this deep in the south when you had the
first winter storm come in you're kind
of like well you know maybe we'll be
okay
but the second one that came in and on
that wednesday the 17th
all bets were off and it was like the
the system just crashed
like a computer 60 minutes plus
correspondent wesley lowry joins us now
wesley good morning thanks for being
here
first question why has the
infrastructure in jackson been allowed
to deteriorate to this point you know
it's interesting and it's not just a
jackson store it's a story of many
cities across the country
right we have to remember that many of
our cities
the their physical skeletons were built
decades ago
in some cases for populations that were
much larger
than the ones today and you look at
jackson specifically
this was a city that was once almost a
quarter million people
but following federally mandated school
desegregation saw
massive demographic shifts within the
city itself
a lot of white flight out to suburbs
leaving
the people behind or the people who were
left behind
tended to be poorer tended to be blacker
fewer businesses
smaller tax base and so suddenly you
have this big city built for many more
people
that is being supported with the
resources of a much smaller tax base and
so
you can see how very quickly suddenly
the city doesn't have
have the resources to keep up uh with
what it would take you know and
infrastructure is not particularly sexy
you know let's spend an extra billion
dollars on water or bridges right it's
something that seems easy to be
to kick from one year to the next and
suddenly you look up and it's been 30
years
wes this is michelle here i wonder you
look at the big picture of
jackson the big picture across the
united states
which communities are most impacted by
this
of course you know there is a close
correlation
uh between race and economics and
whether or not you have clean water in
the united states of america that
that we were talking to experts at the
u.s water alliance and elsewhere and
they said
that the the biggest determinant of
whether or not you have clean water in
america is whether you're black or not
that there are millions of people who
don't have access to clean
drinking water to clean uh sewage and
waste water
and that that correlates very directly
to where you live in a city
where you live uh in the country and we
know that those types of geographic
choices um and geographic realities
were not uh something that were
coincidences so over the course of our
of our recent history decisions have
been made about who gets to live where
and how they're serviced and so
there really is an issue of racial
equity here we all think about flint
um and the conversation about the lead
in the water there
but flint is a story that is not unique
to one particularly bad place or what's
happening in jackson is not unique to
one particular city
this is something that's playing out for
millions of americans across the country
with about 20 seconds how will president
biden's infrastructure plan
impact what we're seeing so they're
still working out the hyper-specific
details but one thing that's important
is that what president biden is
proposing
is in fact a generational investment in
infrastructure again
infrastructure's not particularly sexy
and so folks don't get as excited
necessarily as they might for something
else but that said he's
aiming to spend an amount of money if he
can get it through congress
that really is is unprecedented in our
modern history in terms of the
infrastructure the skeleton
of our country and so it's going to be
really interesting to see if that's
something he can get through washington
um and how that might change things at
communities like jackson
wesley lowry we thank you looking
forward to that report and you can watch
wesley's full report on 60 minutes plus
this sunday
on the viacom cbs streaming service
paramount plus